So let's look at the system
that is not even unusual,
that combines all of these
three forms of parallelism.
So we can have a dual socket motherboard
that has two chips with four cores on
each chip, and each core can
simultaneously run two threads,
using simultaneous multi-threading.
So as far as the programmer is concerned
and as far as the operating system is
concerned, what we really have
is two times four times two.
Which means that 16 threads,
or for that matter,
16 different single-threaded
programs can run simultaneously.
And a relatively simple operating
system would just treat these
as 16 largely equivalent cores.
This can be a big problem.
Because let's say that we actually have
three threads, and the operating system
not knowing any better, just maps them
to the first three threads that it has.
But it turns out that these two
are really threads on the same
core that compete with each other for
issue slots and other things
in an out of order processor.
And then,
really the first half of these threads,
eight of them,
are really on the same chip.
So we're using only half of the overall
cache capacity that the system has.
Pretty much, we have a very large cache
in the other chip that we are not using.
So, a much smarter policy for
using three threads would be
to put them on different
chips if we can and
definitely on different cores if we can,
so that they don't compete.
So the idea would be that
you would first run threads
such that they're
distributed among the chips,
so that you maximize the cache
capacity that you're benefiting from.
Then we also want to make sure that
the first map a thread to each core.
And only then do we want to actually map
threads to the second
thread in each core.
So that if there are fewer threads,
they don't need to share
the resources of the same core.
Each gets its own core.
And that requires the operating system
to actually know what's going on.
So most of the well known operating
systems like Windows, and Linux, and
so on, will actually be
able to figure this out.
But that means that as we have this
fancy hardware that has pluralism
at different levels of granularity,
we also have to make our
operating systems aware of that.
So it's not just expose
more thread contexts that
the operating system can use.
It actually matters how you
use this thread context.